bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un téléphone entre la part encore
beaucoup parler c'est le haut niveau
[Musique]
si vous connaissez au nord ils ont
l'habitude de sortir des produits qui
sont pas forcément très très cher mais
avec des produits de bonne qualité
sonore est une filiale de houaïlou ai
weiwei connu pour avoir des téléphones
qui sont vraiment de bonne qualité et
justement au nord a senti cette année le
guide pro et maintenant ils sont sortis
le au nord de la loire le or neuf et
sortait déjà il ya quelques temps je
voulais attendre avant d'en parler pour
pouvoir regarder par rapport aux
différentes offres aux différents
produits qu'on pouvait trop vite
ressortir en 2017
on a commencé l'année avec le samsung
galaxy et suite il ya une de nos de
suite il ya quelques temps l'iphone
disques qui sortent il n'ya pas
longtemps on a eu plein de nouveaux
smartphones cette année je voulais voir
un petit peu à ceux au nord comment il
se positionner par rapport à l'ensemble
de ses produits
voir ainsi l'intérêt sens il faut
l'acheter oui ou non
et puis on va regarder un petit poucet
différentes caractéristiques techniques
alors j'ai pu l'essayer le prendre dans
les mains le tester complètement et puis
on fera un petit proche d'elle à la fin
et je vous dirai si ça vole couvrir ne
l'achetez pas parler du nouveau
smartphone de honor c'est le au nord 9
en cro lyon on a déjà parlé
ultérieurement bidon pour faire un petit
peu le test et la présentant aujourd'hui
pour un petit peu la qualité est là sur
les spécificités une fois que les
téléphones dans les mains d'un point de
vue design d'un point de vue purement
esthétique c'est un produit qui rappelle
vraiment le au nord 8 alors leur nom 800
un produit qui avait vraiment bien
marché avec son dos vos son dos en verre
alors déjà en termes de prise en main
c'est un bruit qui est plutôt agréable
qui se tient bien dans la main on aura
vraiment une finition très premium très
clairement de
ce produit vous voyez
avec l'aspect vers un aspect très
brillant on a une coque arrière qui est
incurvé avec un aspect 3d ça renforce
vraiment ce côté premium de se produire
à voir qu'on est sur des produits qui
sont loin d'être les plus chers du
marché
il ya vraiment un aspect extrêmement
séduisant l'inconvénient sur les traces
de deux mois je ne sais pas si ça se
boit gala et vous avez plein de traces
de doigts et qui forcément toujours un
petit peu nettoyer si on veut garder le
côté un peu brillant du smartphone cette
année apple a sorti son iphone 10 qui a
également un nouveau en verre et qui
laisse aussi des traces de doigts alors
la seule chose qu'on peut regrette un
petit peu basse à des traces de loi même
si elle est effectivement d'annoncer
quelque chose qui n'était pas très
fragile en terme de traces de doigts
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore le
cas il ya encore des petites
améliorations offertes pour l'instant
les dons envers ses patrons sait très
bien que quoi qu'il se passe le vert
forcément on va garder des traces de
doigts un sas et celles avec des
caractéristiques techniques du verre
malgré tout on peut pas trop et coupé
côté très pratique aussi on a gardé le
bouton de déverrouillage le capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'avant vous
avez un déverrouillage directement avec
votre empreinte digitale sur smartphone
pour un déverrouillage rapide le bouton
pour déverrouiller alors que ça me
saoule les a passées à l'arrière sur les
suites et le nom de suite au nord a fait
le choix sur le au nord 9 de laisser
allemands sachent où c'est très pratique
parce que si vous posez votre téléphone
sur une table et vous avez besoin de le
déverrouiller rapidement vous pouvez le
faire avec votre doigt vous tenant la
main vous pouvez le faire aller chercher
derrière si vous voulez un petit
déverrouillage avec votre doigt alors
vous avez un dos en verre vous allez
continuer à laisser les traces derrière
c'est pas génial ça finira de dire est
d'avoir un produit qui va un peu sale
enfin du moins du point de vue des
traces de doigts donc le fait de l'avoir
à l'avant c'est vraiment un point
positif
il est disponible dans trois coloris
saphir bleu glacier gré et midnight
black l'écran occupe 70% de la face
avant on a un écran
ubs avec une résolution en full hd un
écran 5 points 15 pouces avec une
définition de 428 et pays alors l'écran
fait le job
quand on compare à ce qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs sur le marché à des prix qui
sont pas du tout les mêmes dont il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable
on a vu du
de l'écran oled sur le lg les trans sur
les fans disent que ce soit sur les
samsung galaxy s 8 ou 9 8
quand on retourne sur une dalle ip est
ce comme celle du honneur 9
on est forcément un peu en demi-teinte
fatalement alors les couleurs sont
corrects sont pas extraordinaires
les contrastes sont pas géniaux pas
terrible terrible
après ça fait le job on est sur un
produit qui coûte aujourd'hui moins de
400 euros
là tout de suite je vous comparer des
produits qui sont comme beaucoup plus
cher a facilement deux fois le prix du
honneur neuf donc bon mais il faut
garder une certaine proportion mais
c'est vrai que par rapport à ce qu'on
trouve aujourd'hui sur le marché en 2010
est ce au nord 9 du point de vue de
l'affichage de l'écran c'est parce
qu'ils annulent l'écran tactile aussi
répond bien lorsqu'on sollicite qu'on va
qu'on n'ouvre des applications confère
un conte avis ça marche bien ça répond
très très facilement c'est un écran de
bonne qualité dont c'est très pratique
très simple et très fluide d'utilisation
ça marche bien que tu as ta face on a
une surcouche em 8,5 points et un
androïde 7.0 alors que ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'elle se couche le n
8 5 points ne serait pas largué si vous
utilisez du royaume voulu retrouver sur
wiiware est sûre au nord et ce qui est
bien c'est pour les personnes qui
viennent d'ailleurs est-ce qu'ils ont
eue gltd iphone et bien on retrouve un
petit peu le même caractéristique au
niveau de l'affichage donc c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas trop largué au niveau de
la la navigation haut niveau un peu de
l'interface graphique donc ça c'est vrai
que c'est pratique j'ai fait un petit
tour du stand exploitation c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui tourne
plutôt bien que lorsque je navigue
lorsque je vais ouvrir les applications
à sauver dans les dossiers lorsque je
fais plein de choses ça marche bien
il faut dire que derrière vous avez
quand même un procès sortiez 960 cadencé
à 2,4 ghz
on n'est pas sur les tous derniers
version
des processeurs pour trouver sur un
voyou est par contre quelque chose qui
tourne bien et le modèle que j'ai essayé
avait six giga de ram me semble-t-il en
france on peut le trouver uniquement en
4 gigas de ram
le système est fluide s'ouvre bien les
applications répondent bien on voit
vraiment derrière on a une vraie qualité
au niveau du processeur kirin ça
fonctionne bien ça fait le job pour un
téléphone qui a moins de 80 euros une
fois de plus je le répète mais c'est
vraiment très bien
la plus graphique c'est une mali j'ai 71
m p 8
alors elle fonctionne à merveille vous
pouvez faire tourner des jeux dessus
tout les jeux que vous avez sur
catalogue plestan et vous serez pas
déçus ça tourne ça réagit bien d'un
point de vue graphique s'affiche
correctement pas de latence comprendre
et et par rapport à l'honneur huit pros
qui sortit ya quelques mois c'est que
vous aviez un écran de 7 pouces un peu
plus grand ou plus confortable pour le
jeu là avec le 5,15 pouces bon c'est
bien il va pas cracher dessus mais on
est un petit peu déçu parce que la
taille est inférieure donc quand on veut
jouer à des jeux alors on n'est pas dans
de l'immersion complète on joue quand
même sur un smartphone mais c'est quand
même plus agréable d'avoir un écran un
peu plus grand
par contre avec ce smartphone là avec le
hors-d'oeuvre vous allez oublier la
réalité virtuelle toute façon on
n'allait pas acheter celui là pour avoir
la réalité virtuelle
mais si vous aviez votre petit casque de
réalité virtuelle
si vous ne mettez dessus vu la qualité
vu la lumière vous les contrastes vous
serez très très rapidement déçu
d'ailleurs si vous voulez de la vr
aujourd'hui parce que je recommande ses
soins galaxy ace 7 soit un galaxy et
suite que vous câblée directement sur
votre casque ça marche à merveille et
c'est très bien vous avez une prise jack
vous avez un haut parleur haut parleurs
qui est pas hyper puissant si vous
voulez écouter de la musique que si vous
voulez avoir une conversation via les
haut-parleurs c'est bien mais il faut
pas de bruit ambiant dès lors pris un
petit peu de bruit ambiant
ça sera un petit peu limite limite côté
photo vidéo à mon avis c'est là que le
bât blesse
on sait qu'aujourd'hui la photo et la
vidéo c'est ce cas le plus important
pour moi sera smartphones après bien
évidemment les appels téléphoniques
on n immortaliser les moments se prendre
en photo partager sur les réseaux
sociaux là c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu dommage à la prière on va retrouver
de caméra 2 mégapixels en couleur et un
20 mégapixels monochrome alors point
négatif vous avez un zoom x 2 qui est
proposé le zoom x 2 en réalité n'est pas
du tout un zoom optique mais un zoom
numérique lorsque vous allez faire des
photos avec votre homme vous allez
perdre en qualité et on peut le dire
franchement c'est pas léger sans grain
franchement que au nord n'est pas
améliorer le traitement de ces logiciels
progresser pour avoir un meilleur rendu
au niveau des photos bon ça c'est un
taux de regrets aux siens vraiment des
points négatifs de ce smartphone pour la
vidéo vous pouvez filmer jusqu'à en 4k
uhd alors fondamentalement si vous
voulez profiter d'une bonne qualité
lorsque vous filmez il faut filmer en
full hd
cherchez pas aller au dessus s'est pas
encore vraiment une super bonne qualité
les capteurs jeux sont pas gênés pour ça
vous n'allez pas vraiment profiter
vraiment d'une vraie belle 4k l'honneur
9 fera le job mais filmer uniquement en
full hd sur la fage vous avez ici la
caméra avant si vous voulez filmé avec
l'avant vous avez un capteur en 8
mégapixels alors pour l'avoir testé la
qualité est pas extraordinaire ça fait
le job ça fera 17 filles ça fera des
jolis souvenirs
vous pourrez partager avec vos amis vous
pourrez partager sur les réseaux sociaux
est immortalisé quelques moments si vous
voulez vraiment profité d'une belle
caméra avant pour faire de beaux selphy
à mon sens il faut partir sur un autre
smartphone
côté batterie on a une 3200 milliampères
heures donc normalement pas de surprise
on reste dans les moyennes de ce qui se
fait actuellement sur les smartphones
vous avez plus de treize heures
d'autonomie en utilisation normale
organes évidemment si vous êtes un accro
du jeu vidéo tout le temps dessus tout
en train de naviguer tout le temps en
train de jouer
vous allez consommer beaucoup plus mais
pour une utilisation standard pouvait
avoir une batterie qui dure un peu plus
d'une journée une journée une journée et
demie faut noter que vous avez une
recharge rapide en moins d'une heure et
demie le smartphone est chargé et ça
c'est vraiment un pas positif
côté téléphonie vous avez bien
évidemment un double lecteur de carte
sim que vous retrouvez chaise autres
produits aux doors alors soit un double
lecteur de carte sim soit acteur de
cartes sim et une carte mémoire qu'on
peut remonter jusqu'à 256 giga faut
savoir vous avez 64 giga natif dans le
téléphone
donc si vous voulez mettre plein de
photos plein de vidéos rajouter plein
n'appuyant pas plus que vous voulez dans
de la musique à fond
vous pouvez le faire ça c'est pratique
pour faire en résumé ce smartphone c'est
un bon produit qui coûte aujourd'hui
moins de 400 euros pour les points
positifs face à mettre la finition
premium avec un produit qui est très
jolie ce côté courbée vers combien
l'arrière c'est super joli super élégant
le lecteur d'empreintes digitales
positionné à l'avant fait le job
je vous dis par rapport aux essuie tout
de suite c'est vraiment pas génial
d'aller le chercher à que doit derrière
on prend l'habitude ça marche mais le
placer à l'avant c'est plus facile
lorsqu'il est posé sur une table à vous
pouvez le déverrouiller à mon sens c'est
quand même un vrai point positif
l'autonomie est vraiment correct la puce
graphique fonctionne bien et surtout le
prix qui se positionne à moins de 400
euros vous pouvez le trouver pour 379
euros
point négatif les traces de doigts
l'arrière le produit un aspect premium
mais dès que vous l'utilisez beaucoup
avec vos doigts vous allez laisser des
traces de doigts derrière et ça c'est
pas génial
la qualité des photos les modules photos
que ce soit à l'arrière le double module
ou alors le 8 mégapixels à l'avant
la qualité est pas génial je pense que
je regrette vraiment ce sont les
couleurs les contrastes de la dali ps
alors on va pas à révolutionner ce
produit c'est pas un écran oled
on s'habitue très rapidement aux écrans
oled avec effectivement des contrastes
qui sont saisissants et des couleurs qui
sont magnifiques
quand on arrive sur une dalle ip est ce
forcément on est un petit peu en demi
teinte donc ça aujourd'hui par rapport à
ce qu'on trouve sur le marché
c'est un peu dommage après pour un
produit à moins de 400 euros c'est pour
moi un très bon smartphone donc est-ce
qu'il faut l'acheter
oui et non pour moi ça dépend d'une
chose d'un facteur principal c'est votre
budget si vous voulez un smartphone qui
marche bien sur lequel vous allez
pouvoir avant l'utilisation classique si
vous voulez pas trop des photos du super
bonne qualité si vous voulez utiliser
des jeux pour vous amuser
si vous voulez un aspect à peu près miom
pour moi le honor 9v vraiment le jaune
si maintenant vous voulez des très
belles photos si votre truc c'est
vraiment de faire de la vidéo de la
photo de la bonne qualité de vous les
partager sur les réseaux sociaux avec
bien retour du traitement d'image très
clairement ce produit ne fera pas le job
à mon sens donc c'est pas celui là qu'il
faut choisir
mais je vous dis pour utilisation de
classiques pour avoir un bon smartphone
c'est vraiment bien
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui sur les odeurs 9 dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez mais moi un
petit commentaire a dit mme savard est
ce que vous l'avez acheté oui non est-ce
que vous lâchez rien
est-ce que ce téléphone répondrai à vos
demandes est ce que au nord vous aimez
cette marque
qu'est ce que vous trouvez qu'elle est
intéressante par rapport aux autres
fabricants par rapport à samsung par
rapport à apple wayuu mêmes avec leurs
l'europe produit je pense à tous les
nouveaux produits de
wei wei sorti cette année au mois de
plus au nouveau roi de +5 tekki
également sorties dites moi ce que vous
en pensez comment est ce que vous le
situer et est ce que c'est un produit
qui vous séduire et et sinon ben
pourquoi écrit qu'elle produit vous
prendriez voilà merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo on se retrouve très très
très bientôt passe pour encore plus de
contenu pour parler de high tech de
téléphonie de table est de tout ce que
vous voulez il ya énormément de choses
plein de surprises qui vous attendent
vous invite à vous abonner année c'est
un joli pouce si vous êtes intéressés
étaient prêtes ou vos commentaires
violents discutent ensemble très
rapidement merci a bientot portez vous
bien
ciao